well as the uk deals with this amber
extreme heat warning the dry weather
across the uk has caused some water
companies to impose hose pipe bans
however they have been receiving
criticism themselves of their handling
of supplies with some calling for bosses
bonuses to be put on hold let's talk to
the head of media and pr for angling
water regan harris um reagan your boss
got 3.5 million pounds in bonuses
recently yet your company's been fined
three times for polluting in the last
year why are they worth the money
well i mean it's not really for me to
comment on exactly human
remuneration when you are here right in
the company
that deals with peer-to-peer reviews
what i can say is that our company
performance is directly linked to chief
exact bonus and bonuses across our
senior management and those have been
significantly reduced this year because
we recognized that our performance
wasn't where it needed to be
but reduced but still 3.5 million pounds
most people
looking at those figures will say that's
an extraordinary figure for a water
company to be giving to its bosses when
when you appear to still be polluting
rivers and and killing fish
well we're very clear on the fact that
our environmental performance needs to
be addressed and needs to be changed we
absolutely should not be discharging um
using csos as a way to manage um an
overload into a system absolutely not
but the the um
bonuses of our chief exec reflected
other areas where we were leading the
industry like tackling leakage for
example um but where we knew that
environmental performance was not where
we wanted it to be that's where we saw
exec pay across the board cut this year
and our focus now is very much on
dealing with the job at hand which is
keeping taps running
during unprecedented weather
we've seen the driest eight months since
1976 and as a water company we're you
know we're doing a good job at that um
we have not
implemented any host pipe bands as yet
and nor do we forecast the need to this
summer um and we are doing you know all
our doing our job of keeping taps
running for people across the east of
england
but is that because you're not having a
host pipe ban uh because the part of the
uk that you are covering is less dry
than than the southeast it is the most
dry parts of the uk that are being
affected by these hosepipe bands the
weather isn't quite as hot and angler as
it is in kent no i'm afraid that that's
simply not true the east of england is
the driest part of the uk and we get a
third less rainfall than anywhere else
um but we are incredibly resilient we
are prepared to deal with dry hot dry
hot summers um and we have created
invested um millions of pounds into
resilience over the last 30 years to
make sure we've got the infrastructure
in place to deal with dry hot summers
and that's exactly what we do we're very
agile at moving water around storing
water where we need it most but also we
recognize the need to invest now for the
future um and that's why we're bringing
online plans for new strategic pipelines
um to bring water from the north of our
region to the south and also we have
plans in in future for new reservoir
options as well
what about leakage you're obviously very
keen to to talk about
successes you've had in terms of leakage
but of what wants water companies to try
to reduce their leakage by 16 the latest
figures for anglian water show that
you've managed to reduce it by 6.1
percent that's nowhere near what off
what are hoping you would do well
actually the targets are off what set us
for last year alone we've exceeded those
in that six percent and we're already
the best water company in the industry
when it comes to tackling low leakage um
and we've got the lowest by more than
half compared to the rest of any other
water companies
but we know we need to go further
but currently we're actually you know
overtaking other european countries in
terms of driving down leakage to be
world world leaders in low leakage so we
know we need to go further but we made a
decision over a decade ago to go beyond
what our regulators asked us to do and
that's why we're you know quite simply
the best in the industry at driving down
leakage
but locally there are huge issues aren't
there i've seen that you know one local
mp has called bosses of angling water
diabolical uh and that was just uh in
the last couple of months because of sue
at the sewer saga and boston road south
in hull beach there are a number of
local issues that that clearly local
people would like to see the company
doing a great deal more on and we
absolutely committed to doing that um
you know there have been local issues
just as i'm sure lots of other water
companies have seen during the prolonged
dry weather where we have had you know
pipes bursting because of dry ground
conditions um and you know things have
been difficult for you know the last few
months but we've got more teams than
ever out on the ground finding leaks
fixing leaks
managing our water resources to make
sure we can keep up with demand and as i
said the most important thing as well is
not just demand for today and tomorrow
but for next summer as well um what we
need to be mindful of now is you know
how much rainfall we get this winter
because we certainly will be in a more
serious position next summer without
that rainfall but currently things are
looking stable for us in terms of our
reservoirs and groundwater levels so
that this moment in time there's no need
for any any restrictions from the
anglian water region
and in terms of those river levels
you're watching them very very closely
does that come a point where they do go
what is the trigger point at which point
you will say hang on that they have now
got so low we are going to have to start
bringing in other measures
but this this is all based on our
drought plans which we agree as water
companies with the environment agency um
they are based on science and monitoring
and you know prolonged predictions for
water resources across our region and
we're absolutely committed to following
that as a process and working with the
environment agency monitoring river
levels and storage levels across the
region um you know and people should you
know be assured that when we reach those
trigger points where we might need to
implement some stuff the next year or
you know next spring and summer then
we'll absolutely do that if that's the
right thing to do to protect the
environment but we're certainly not
there at the moment
and that's really testament to the
investments we've made for resilient
infrastructure and just being good at
moving water successfully around our
region to where it's needed most
reagan harris from anglian water good to
talk to you thanks very much for joining
us today